Good afternoon, Brenda.
Hi, Max, how are you?
I'm doing good, how about you?
Pretty good, pretty good. Just a busy day.
Jerry's out this week. Well, Jerry's out this week and Brandon's still out for vacation. So it's for me, it's very busy.
Maybe Monday 3.0.
Oh, okay.
Mm-hmm.
So, it's all on your shoulders then, right?
It is. It is. But how fun is that? I know you know what that means, Max. It hadn't ever happened to you, has it? Come on.
Yeah.
Yeah, yes, yes, I'm aware about it.
I can understand. First of all, I congratulate, I have two things to congratulate you on. That is for completion of 20 years with turnkey solutions. That's a huge milestone, 2 decades.
Thank you.
Yeah, Brandon is right behind me in a couple of years. So him and I were, yeah.
Okay, so...
So you're senior to him in this phase. Yeah, that's right. Good. And the second one, I sent a text on that one as well. That was to get the award second in a row. That's again, a marvellous achievement.
Yeah.
Thank you. Yeah, we're proud of our, we're proud of that. So.
Yeah, Deirdre.
Hi, Vishal.
The.
Hey, Max, very good afternoon, Brenda.
Hi, good afternoon.
So just congratulating Brenda for the award as well as for completing 20 years with turnkey solutions. Two decades, man.
Oh, that is some achievement, Brenda. Congratulations. Hatiest congratulations on that.
Thanks. Thank you very much. I appreciate it.
Are we expecting Brandon to join today or yes?
Hayre so.
No, Brandon's on vacation. Yeah, that's what I was just telling Max that I've been very busy because both Jerry, who's in projects, and Brandon are out on vacation. So it's just a little busy.
Yeah, I tried to, yeah, I tried to reach out to you, Dave, for yesterday, but then I realized that, you know, it's been really, really busy time for you, and...
Mm.
Play.
Oh, I'm sorry. I missed it completely. I'm so sorry.
No, it's absolutely fine. I was just trying to conclude the conversation we had on Friday and then you spoke about one incident. So I was just trying to reach out to you to just conclude that part. But it's absolutely fine. I know you have been really busy.
Mhm.
Okay.
Okay, great. Back to you, Max. Thank you so much.
Thank you, Vishal. So, Brenda, I am going to start presenting my screen. Hi.
Give me one moment, let me see once you're able to see it.
K.
Should be there any moment.
Okay.
Okay, I see it now.
Perfect. Brenda, I welcome you to our monthly business review. The data we are going to talk about is from...
Ohh.
K.
Oh, I think my note taker jumped in. Okay, yeah, I have it set to automatically join, so I totally forgot about it. There we go. Okay, that's fine.
Yeah.
Okay.
Perfectly all right. No issues. Yeah, I was saying I welcome you to our monthly business review. So this is the, we're going to talk about like the agenda that we have is we'll be talking about his highlights. We'll be talking about the Hazel's improvement plan. We'll be going through the performance analysis.
talk about build IT, way forward, and the recap. That is something that I'll be updating the slide before I share it with you.
Okay, so talking about the highlights, if you talk about highlights, Alice, she's taking care of, she's taken care of dispatch for 60s in last month, in the month of May. And for Hazel, backup sheets and backup status, she's taking care.
care of and she also started handling the after inbound calls. So whenever the call lands in, when she's available, she's the one who picks it up. Derek, if you talk about him, he's taken care of for the automate and screen connect integration. That was a log pending thing, I believe, that was going on.
And that was addressed, and he also addressed the browser sync issues for the client domains on automated as well. So, these were the things that he took care of, and I'm aware that he is he started late today because he is...
Yes.
going to take care of the firewall upgrade for GDI as well. That is going to be the after task for him.
Yeah.
Okay, so moving on to next, Hazel's improvement plan. Vishal and you had a call on Friday. I'm aware about that. Though we still have the things going on, but we're still monitoring the process and like we'll be updating you as well on that.
Okay.
No, I just want to have some word on this, Brenda. It's been some time, you know, I know you feel that things are moving in the right direction or, you know, she's feeling better. Although Friday incident, you said that if we had a call on Thursday, you may have a different feedback for her.
I was discussing that internally. It's been like three to four months and...
If I look into your feedback, I believe she's still not there where you really want her to be. And where even we are expecting that she should be able to do everything independently. She has started doing that maybe more than 80% she's there, but still.
Mhm.
Hi.
where she starts making you happy and where you start having some independent or you can say some dependency on her that okay, if Hazel is there, she's going to do that. I don't think we are really there, right? I was discussing.
No, she still has to reach out to our technician here. And then, you know, as you mentioned, the incident that was, you know, last week.
Yeah, yeah, I spoke about that incident and I will, I took her feedback. She said that, you know, when she sent that backup sheet to you, that particular backup that was still in progress state, so that is why she didn't mention anything and she just mentioned in progress. Maybe she did everything correct from KPI standpoint, what we are expecting her to do so.
But then I definitely assume, as a backup engineer, if she knows this is a critical backup, and then she has to keep an eye on that just throughout the day, and she she has to mention it to the to you or other stakeholders that, hey, this backup is still in progress. I'll keep an eye in case if it it goes fail or if it.
succeeds over there. Before she ends her day, she has to give us the update. It's maybe her KPI says that this is once 24 hour job that you know you have to review it once in 24 hours, but that is where we expect tenure people to, you know, go beyond, go extra mile to understand.
Right.
Okay.
But...
What is the what is the criticality of that backup?
Yeah, and we call it taking ownership of the problem and that that was my issue that someone had to go in and find it. And to be perfectly honest, you know that unless someone if they are just nobody else, that's when I'm going to check backups because that's not my not my cup of tea, so I would have never even.
Absolutely, absolutely.
Yes.
Yes, yes. No, I totally understand.
thought to go check that. But he did just, I think he had worked on the server or something. It just so happened that and it was disconnected and had it stayed like that, you know, it could have been a problem. So I think that's where I'm coming from.
Yes, yep, so that is yep.
Mhm.
Absolutely, I totally agree to you. Ownership is the right word you just mentioned. That is not 100% there. I know she's a sincere kid. She's trying her level best. So if I look into the, you know, bigger picture over there, first of all, I don't have, you know, words to say thank you for all your patience.
You, Brandon, you have been really, really supportive. You know, you feel that, you know, if there is someone in your team, you give enough opportunities for them to grow, to learn, right? But now I feel, Brenda, that we have to look for a change. If she's still not there, and if you see lack of ownership for any X, Y, Z, maybe she's doing 9.
Yes.
out of 10 things great, but on one thing that is critical if she continues to miss out, even I don't have any words to defend, right? So especially after Friday's incident, I went back to Sameer, my boss, and I told him that we tried everything, but I cannot play more with, you know,
Brenda or Brandon's patience over there doesn't work for me, right? So what I did, I found a strong person. When I say strong, he's working like a shift lead right now for me. He was working for another client. His name is Axton. I'm going to propose his resume to you. Okay, I was expecting to meet Brandon on this call, but I can send it over to you and Brandon together. And once.
you know, you just review that together or you can just check it right away. We can have you to have a call with him. So one week, my proposal is that at least for the first week or 1st 10 days when he will just go through the KT process or he will just, you know, he'll just try to understand your environment.
All right.
That is absolutely on us. We are not going to put you any.
And you have to understand this is very painful on our side. We have been a very long time without a strong person on backups. So I've been a very long time, yes.
I totally understand that. I totally understand that. And that is where, trust me, a Friday call, I was embarrassed to hear those all things because till Thursday, even I was very much confident. I will be honest over there because me and Max, we have been checking with her. She looks good and she has.
Mhm.
you know, come a long way. And I'm pretty sure she has learned that or earned that experience or that thing over there. But Friday, after Friday incident, I don't think I can take any risk with this partnership, Brenda. I'm very, very honest. And that is where when I went back to Sameer, I told him that I don't have, you know, face to, you know, be in front of Brandon.
continue talking about that, okay, we are working on this plan and she should be there. I cannot continue to do so. So that is where, you know, he gave me this very strong resume. I'm going to send that over to you. His name is Axton. As I said, he's working as a shift lead. So he's handing a kind of shift, you know, three or four people in the backup team. So.
Right.
Yeah.
I'm just pulling in, I'm pulling in from a very strong team.
I understand and I'm really not trying to be argumentative. It's just been we have not had a strong backup person since Tia, literally since Tia left. We've had problems with, we had problems with Avery, we had problems with Varric, we've had, you know, with Denise. So it's very, it's kind of a really raw, touchy subject on this side.
S.
And we're keeping told that these people are very strong backups, and yet, you know, here we are. So I don't...
I mean, I understand your position too. I mean, I'm a manager. I get that. I completely understand that you're somewhat of a control of your engineers, but in other aspects, you just can't sit right there beside and like day after day. I mean, I understand that too. So you just kind of have to understand our
Our our side of everything, you know, like even even your proposal now for a new technician kind of.
I kind of have to just exhale, you know, because it's pain points because it's still things that they don't know in our environment that the other folks may have known, you know.
I tell you one thing. No, no, I tell you one thing. I tell you one thing. The plan, what I'm coming with right now, I totally understand your situation, Brenda. That is where I was saying that the person I'm going to propose, okay, when he's going through your KT process, he's trying to understand the environment, okay, as long as, you know, it could be 10 days or...
But.
Mhm.
Uh-huh.
two weeks, that is absolutely on us. You don't have to pay anything for that.
Mhm.
So that is where I understand your situation, right? Trust me, I was going to propose Axton in Jen when we lost Denise. He was my go-to person at that point of time, but he was working with a partner where we were not in a position to get him from there.
So that is where I waited for almost 10 days for him, but he was not able to, we were not able to get him from there. I mean, I'm in a position right now to be there. He's a kind of, he can start immediately on this account. And the transition period, it could be one week, it could be two week, it could be anything like that, you know.
Mhm.
Mm.
That is on us. So money part, you don't have to worry for that. If you don't like him during the two weeks or three weeks, I'll respect your decision. That's what I'm saying.
Okay.
Yeah, that is that is on me and that is on me. That's what I'm saying.
Right.
Yeah. Okay. Well, Brandon will be back. Yeah, Brandon will be back. He, you know, he is the overall approver of this and he'll be back next week. I probably when Monday is probably not going to be great. But I will, I will give a preview, you know, of the proposal.
Okay.
Yes, yes, yes.
Yes.
For sure.
Maybe, maybe I'm asking for a personal favor from you, Brenda, that please look into this and, you know, and then I'll definitely go to Brandon as well, because this this partnership has been has been really important and more than just a partnership, this is something that that has been a blessing for me, because when I started with with...
Sure.
Yeah.
With ITBD, this is this was my first account. OK, and I always say first one is always special, right? So that is where I I always try to be there, you know, personally, and that is where I was I was monitoring Hazel as well. Unfortunately, things didn't go that well, but I'm...
Okay.
Yeah.
I'm very confident with Axton because he's a shift lead. So the kind of person you're looking for, I'm pretty sure he is the one. I'll send it over to you. I'm not going to add more into that. OK, I just want to let you know how important it is for me. Don't worry for the transition period or anything that is on us.
Okay.
Mhm.
I'll take care of that.
Okay.
Okay, I appreciate that. Thank you so much, Max. Sorry, I never meant to hijack the agenda, but I really want to talk about this important piece with Brenda. And Brenda, again, I don't have enough words to appreciate your patience on that.
No worries, yeah, this is.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Thank you, Vishal. Thank you, Brenda. I'm going to continue with the presentation. One moment, let me start sharing my screen. Okay, so I believe it is visible.
Sure.
Yes.
Perfect. Okay, moving on to the next phase, that is a performance analysis. If we talk about the numbers for Alice, it was 83 percent. Like there was one PTO and one holiday for her. And she, as I mentioned, that she did.
Uhh...
the dispatch for the team. However, during that dispatch period, she also took care of some of the tickets, like the tickets that she could handle on her own, like without letting them hit the engineers. So she took care of those and she was able to get them closed as well. Any questions?
Here, before I move on to the next one.
No, that's fine.
Okay, so talking about Derek, 73% billable utilization that he achieved. There were two PTOs that he took and there was one of the holidays. Usually the utilization is above the target, but this is one time that he was below, but he picked up.
in the last three weeks. The first week was the one where he took the two PTOs and there are no exceptions for the PTOs.
Okay.
Okay, so moving on to the next one for Hazel, numbers, as we talked about the KPI, she's meeting the KPIs, but we just touched on that, the ownership part. So billable is 96% for her with 4% of non-billable. No PTOs in the month of May.
But there was one holiday that was for Memorial Day.
Okay, so I'll move on to the next part. This is the ticket resolution or the ticket resolve rate. Okay, so.
Started with 69% in the first week. Then it went up to 100% because that was the week that she was doing the dispatch. So whatever ticket she could work on, she closed them out. That's why it was 100%. And then the following weeks were 69.
and 82 so that with that she was able to close it out at 80% that is right on target.
Okay.
Okay, so moving on to the next part for Derek, 96% is the closure rate, 155 tickets he worked on and 148 tickets he was able to close out. Any questions here?
No.
Okay, so for Hazel, 94% is the closure rate, 208 tickets she worked on, 194 she was able to close out. Majority of the tickets are predefined tickets for her and the remaining ones are the ones that she creates in case there are backup failures.
So 94% is the closure rate that she hit.
Alright.
Okay, so talking about like the things that we have as far the ITBD is concerned, that is AI by design, our automation tool that we're using right now, the AI integration, and that is part of our, I'll cover it up in the next one as well.
the build IT even so we will be having the AI conference in there as well. So in it, and we have talked about it in past, so I'm not sure whether you are coming to this time for build IT. In case you're not, feel free to, I'll ask Natalie to get in touch with you if we can go ahead and.
ask you to come to this event, that would be a great help. It will be a great exposure for you, us, everyone.
Okay.
Got it.
I know Brandon is going to join right on for us on build IT. Oh, okay.
I think so. I'm not certain. I think so, but I'm not. I'm not 100% certain.
Mhm.
Okay, I'll ask Natalie to follow up with you on that.
Okay, so Team GPS are homegrown software that you're already using. So there will be new features added to it. I believe those will be showcased during the build IT. So in case you have any questions for us, feel free to let us know, and I can arrange a call back.
Yeah.
Okay.
Okay, so talking about way forward, check-ins are going to continue. Hazel to focus on the backup and patching process. As I mentioned, Derek will be working on the DDI firewall upgrades today evening, and then he will be working on the switch upgrades and maybe the new projects which might be coming in.
So that's what she will be taking care of. Alice to continue. Like I know that she is dispatching, going to dispatch for next week, right?
I'm not certain on that. I may need her on tickets next week. We'll have to see. The in the Heather's been out a couple of days and I just did it myself. So to keep her to keep Alice on the ticket side. So we'll see.
She will be OK.
Okay.
Mm.
Perfect. Okay, and then the security audits, these are the monthly tasks or the periodic tasks that she will be taking care of. So that's what we have as the way forward. So that brings us to the end of our presentation. I thank you for your time today.
The.
for going through this presentation and I'll be sharing the copy of this presentation with you and Brandon, do let us know in case you have any questions.
Okay, sure will.
OK, so before we wrap it up, Brandon, Brenda, anything you want to add in?
No, I don't think so.
Perfect, and Vishal, I know that we've done some talking. Anything else apart from that you want to add in over here?
No rest, I'm good. Thank you so much, Max. Thank you so much, Brenda, for your time.
Thank you, Vishal. And I am so sorry I missed your chat. I normally, Max knows, even if I wake up in the middle, I usually reply back if I see it. I'm so sorry.
Yeah.
No, no, please don't say that. Most of the things did that, that is on me, Brenda. I'm trying to cover up. So I appreciate your patience and no complaints, trust me on that.
Okay.
Okay, alright.
Thank you so much.
Okay, thank you, Brenda. Thank you, Vishal, for your time. Have a great day and we'll catch up soon.
Thank you. I hope you all have a great day as well. Thank you. Okay. Bye-bye.
You too. Thank you.
Thank you so much.